all right first welcome to Taylor
Swift's new music video called the men
in which she is a caricature of what
people think like the world looks like
and apparently I've never lived in it
right I'm assuming Taylor Swift lives in
like a giant ivory bubble floating in
the sky and she's never actually come
down to earth to talk with the regular
human beings that live here no sounds
like rich people Hollywood Oh totally
she's worth three hundred sixty million
dollars and she put out a music video
called the man where like there's I mean
one of the lines is I don't want to
wonder how far I would I'm paraphrasing
sound another song she's like I wonder
how far I would have gotten if I was a
man and like everyone would respect me
and would they wouldn't question if I
deserved it or whatever it's like dude
you're like the whole thing they do is
is questioning whether men deserve the
promotions they get like in birds of
prey yeah the one motivation was the guy
got a promotion over the cop and he
didn't deserve it you're literally
questioning whether he deserved it what
are you talking about you do the same
thing anyway no but take a look at this
here's a guy it's actually Taylor Swift
and make up manspreading
and he's smoking us it was she's smoking
a cigar and flicking ashes on people
dude I get it it's an exaggeration but
in no way does anything like that ever
exist in New York now the lady would
smack you in the face
Oh bag oh yeah could you imagine
solutely especially being in like South
Brooklyn I mean a little what do you do
york for 15 years I never saw this sure
I saw people I saw guys and girls it's
not a gender thing it's people that are
rude that don't care but no we're back
up spread and this is ridiculous
obviously it's over exaggeration but
it's I get it supposed to be no I think
they think this stuff is real I think I
agree I think they think it's real that
there's people out there that are this
bad
they actually New York because the
people who run New York don't actually
take the trains like there's this big
thing where yeah Bloomberg was claiming
they took the train and then some want
some journalist caught him with like I'm
armed SUV driving to the train station
and him walking on the stairs like they
drove him there
yeah they don't actually know it's like
so they put up they put up these Flyers
all over New York Metro saying you know
no manspreading you know femme bag
I'm assuming I do family bagging putting
your bags up so no men have a ton of
bags and I put their bags on stuff and
you know what I say you know you want to
know what I do one surefire method to
deal with these entitled women and their
femme bags it's this excuse me can I sit
down and then she goes okay no my thank
you
yep that's it like yeah I'm kidding by
the way New Yorkers are like that though
no but I mean like no no most people on
the train would back you up if you were
like hey could you can you move your
bags so I can sit down and they're like
no everyone around would be like woah
why are you being so rude like let him
sit down that's everyone forgot each
other back feels like that one in ten
million I know if there was a lady with
bags sitting down I bet I can I said
she'd go yeah and she move her bags no
questions asked yeah like nobody cares
what if you came up on a guy who was man
spreading and he said excuse me sir can
I sit here what do you think would
happen he'd say oh I'm sorry
he's on the phone and I pay attention
there was no one next to him anyway so
they're sitting comfortable hey can I
sit next year oh yeah sure
no question I'm in a conversation like I
oh yeah okay not paying attention but
anyway now we're on this men's Bret
man's brain thing the point is the whole
video is like this so and stop but so
she then like as a man she pissed on the
wall pees on a wall in public yeah you
can go for that you couldn't get you can
be a registered sex offender for that
yeah that's public exposure yeah and
it's like so so okay I want to be fair I
get it she's making an exaggeration but
this what the problem is you've got a
bunch of young people who watch this
stuff and it's this is ideal laundering
what happens is yeah Taylor Swift was
not political for a long time and then a
bunch of people started claiming it was
proof that she was like far right or
something so she recoiled in the other
direction and now she's put out a ton of
videos and content that makes literally
no sense because it was clearly written
by some 60 year old guy who was a
democratic consultant case in point yep
the other her other video you need to
calm down so this one's from June you
need to calm down and my question is
like who yeah let me see I talk I really
don't have that so you have people
in around with signs and like you know
first of all one of them's got a
Sciences like [ __ ] or whatever I get
that she's you know Adam and Eve not
Adam and Steve like that was something
that was being said wasn't like a 90s
yeah so who's who's saying that right
now who are you talking about yeah I
don't get it and why are they doing a
caricature of poor people like this is
the crazy thing the contrast here is
that I understand you try to make him
look like crazy or whatever so this
song's called you need to calm down and
she has a bunch of LGBTQ people like
dancing and winking and smiling they're
all clean shaven clean-cut wearing very
very well dressed very well dressed and
she and like they're wearing wealthy
expensive clothes in a very nice you
know well relatively nice it's a trailer
park but they're like the distinction
between her and the people she's
criticizing in the song are that they're
just poor people that look like they're
covered in dirt that's interesting to me
like is that who she thinks are the
people that are coming out and
protesting so so first of all I get the
message
she says throwing some shade never made
anyone less gay or home like that right
I'm like I get it get it can you can you
can you tell can you point to me right
now who in our society is saying you
shouldn't be gay because I'm pretty sure
the present to the United States who is
absolutely not perfect on LGBTQ rights
unfurled an LGBTQ rainbow flag and like
a major Republican convention and got a
like this era is is like long gone well
and those people that you're pointing to
are they only yelling at like Adam Steve
not or Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve
or are they yelling at everyone because
they are they're yelling at everyone
right injecting anything that pisses
them off they're yelling at so they're
just like catering to like oh well
they're yelling at us for one sentence
so like that's our mood enemy you want
to know what one of the craziest things
I've ever heard in my life was hmm
Alyssa Milano's podcast and she was
interviewing this woman who used to work
for Breitbart okay and while the briber
woman was explaining that they would
just put out talking points from from
the Center for Immigration Studies what
she called propaganda you hear this low
chanting in the background slowly
getting louder you want to know what and
then you hear a low hum button
shaking as this woman's going like and
we would get these press releases and
just put it out and I'm listening and
I'm like wait a minute the chanting is
getting louder and then by the end of it
it was full-on charlottesville chanting
from the alt-right people marching
chanting crazy stuff and I'm loud
outside of her building or something or
no no no no no she put the audio in the
interview are you kidding you conflate a
news organization talking about
immigration to a bunch of people with
tiki torches chanting and I'm like these
people are insane so so when so here's
the thing I saw this Taylor Swift song
and it's like her whole new album is
basically woke but it's fake
like they live in this paranoid reality
that doesn't exist where men are
splitting cigar ashes on people and like
spreading their legs I'd say it was an
exaggeration like a joke but they
literally write articles and an act
there was this article this video from I
think Mike calm about man spreading okay
it was totally fabricated so thing but
it was it was amazing a stupid the
viewers were so it had one it has like
1.4 million views I don't last time I
checked mostly thumbs downs I think
people who watched it realize it's fake
but this woman who I will not name says
look at this man sitting here when these
three what while spreading his legs
taking up two other seats and these two
women can't even sit down and it frees
his frame yet the whole trains empty and
I'm and so I was talking to my friend
about it cuz she watched a video and she
was like look you need to see this this
is crazy and I was like I deposit then
she pause it and I was like the lady in
the video just said the guy's blocking
the seats right she's like yeah and I'm
like what's behind those women and she's
like what I'm like the women are looking
at a man spreading his legs what's
behind the women and she was like I
don't know I'm like empty seats yeah so
they're not sitting down why she's like
oh they want to sit right there next to
no they didn't want to sit down they
didn't point they didn't make they were
standing as it felt like standing yeah
I'm like you literally made this problem
it doesn't exist and this is the thing
about that's most mind-blowing about the
Taylor Swift video yeah is what she's
basically doing is criticizing that like
25 men on the planet who can afford a
yacht and can do whatever they want
because they're super rich and acting
like literally if
was a man I'd be like that yeah maybe
you're worth 360 million dollars yeah I
love it that tweet that says that this
is so hypocritical she because she
probably makes more than 99% of the men
on the planet no no who ever lived
Oh ever live you're right excuse me
Taylor Swift makes more money than 99.9
percent of men who ever lived
cool so there's this article someone
wrote about it and it's actually kind of
funny it says Taylor Swift's the man
isn't to take down of toxic masculinity
it's about settling scores well I don't
know what she's settling scores with
because she is look man relative to all
humans who have ever lived or who are
alive today the the amount of people who
have the power and privilege she does
it's it's basically a statistical
anomaly they're so few who are worth
three hundred and sixty plus million
dollars like I don't know hundreds to
thousands maybe out of billions so she
is quite literally at the top I think
she just wanted to dress up as a man I
think well I think I said she just
wanted to be a man forever for a music
video and thought it that this is the
best way to do it so take a look at this
though mm-hmm there was this big thing
that happened where she was posting on
Instagram that you Scooter Braun or
whatever was gonna be bought her music
and was stealing it from her or
something
okay and she what she did was like very
typical you know victim culture whatever
you signed a contract and then your
music got sold this is just normal
business but she tried using social
leverage and woke points to win a legal
battle I think it worked I don't know
what happened but she's posting through
and and and this would really destroy
people's business she was using the
weight of our social power to get what
she wants I'm not saying she's right or
wrong in this legal battle no no what I
am saying is I think it's absolutely
disgusting and hypocritical when she
makes content consistently arguing like
look at this one this okay first of all
that's silly check this out this one
this one made me really really laugh so
male Taylor Swift whatever his name is
is sitting in a park and he Pat's a
little girl in the head and I was like
oh is she gonna tell the truth about
what happens when a man Pat's a little
girl in the head in public and then
everyone runs around cheering for the
guy and I'm like wait what if a bearded
man who
walked up to a little girl and start
patting on the head people would grab
you and call the police and accuse you
of all sorts of nasty things oh yeah
pedophile yeah and and and and and here
in this it's like they're holding up
abandon says world's greatest dad what
are you talking about mothers win like
85% of custody cases it's like
ridiculous yeah there was that dad
walking with his like four-year-old
daughter in the mall and they had
security called on him because they were
like oh you're kidnapping it's like it's
my daughter what right right but it
happens world is this this next scene in
the video so I do want to point out I
understand there's a bit of
tongue-in-cheek in this I'm not you know
[ __ ] devoid of humor yeah the issue is
that she has made statements about this
that are like she legit feels this way
the lyrics aren't a joke the song is not
a parody it's not she's not Weird Al
she's literally saying I wonder how well
I would have done if I was a man it's
like uh I gotta be honest Taylor if you
were dude you'd be worth nothing you
know why
pretty so so she is a tall blond hair
blue-eyed white woman and she her dad
was eight was a stockbroker for I think
Merrill Lynch who paid who was headed a
Montessori School and she got vocal and
guitar lessons well I don't want to
overstate her guitar lessons I think it
was like a local handyman who was
teaching her guitar so that's fair
skills what she had parents who had
access yeah and they used that to put
her in good schools and give her all the
privilege in the world and now she is
one of the most powerful people ever and
she is complaining about it that's the
perfect example exemplified by this
scene in her video her as a man yelling
and screaming at the tennis referee or
whatever you know why this is funny
mm-hmm it's a reference in my opinion I
believe to Serena Williams yes thank you
Serena Williams who is a black woman but
also one of the most powerful
individuals on the planet who is worth
in the tens of millions of dollars who
got in trouble for throwing a fit and
then argued it was about racism and
sexism it's the perfect example of what
these people do they have more power
than literally everyone on the planet I
said literally but almost entirely
everyone you're right and then they go
I'm a victim oh okay you will cry me a
river' oh you're on a million dollar
mansion in Santa Monica I don't want to
hear it
alright you go talk to the people in the
inn you know these small towns that are
falling apart is the end of
tres collapse the people who are
suffering with opioids and then you make
a video saying if I was a man I'd do
better we mean do better three and sixty
million dollars better than that come on
better no no it's not just that it's
that this politics aligns with people on
the far left who say how much is too
much I don't know ask Taylor Swift I
think maybe more than a hundred million
how about that yeah so I don't I don't
know what you do after you're worth a
hundred million dollars but Taylor Swift
apparently wants more where are the
people coming out and criticizing her
calling her the privileged elite I'm
sure there are to be fair true but she's
using their politics and they accept it
and they cheer for it why because
they're hypocrites 220 million views 1
million what four days four days yeah
four days maybe five days well we're on
the fifth day so you you know you could
the the comments obviously 1 million
people like it she's singing about how
you know if I was the man I'd be the man
and all that stuff and it's like dude
you are more powerful than the man you
can literally put out a post on
Instagram to destroy a contract that's
been in place for 20 years 15 years how
many men do you think she has working
for her what does that make her she's
literally the boss yes the man she is
the man yeah she is that she's the men
the man is a reference to the
establishment power exactly and when she
makes a video that disparages men or
tries to convince women their lives suck
she is the establishment power of
manipulate manipulating people and I'll
tell you what I wouldn't be surprised if
a bunch of younger people are like what
a loser to her granted that's probably
not the case she's got 81 thumbs down
and a million thumbs up but maybe
there's some real punk rock people out
there I don't know
I bet Gen Z is not real taken with that
with with her acting which is a victim
yeah and then at the end the funniest
thing is it ends with like the scene
where she's directing it and the male
version of her walks over like it's
Dwayne Johnson voicing it and he's like
how did I do and she's like well you
could do better
you know she says can you be a little
more sexy yeah and it's like okay that
doesn't that doesn't happen either right
can you be a little more sexy like they
they cast you because they think you're
yours actually right right that's why
you got the job
but then she yells down there got like
hey good
job site she yells to the girl over
though the girl hey hey Veronica
you're doing wonderful keep up the great
work hey those are always super nice to
each other like oh they live in a world
that may no no no it's not gosh
they live in a world they made up yes
yes like they read a book and they're
like this is what's really happening and
they make videos about it and they're
convincing people the stuff happens
right doesn't happen no it doesn't it
isn't that's great most people I meet
are very nice and they're chill and it's
I'm talking all races it doesn't matter
most people I meet are cool across the
board done I don't know I don't
understand this world I just think that
her doing this is a reaction to the
people calling her you know alt-right or
whatever because she was like I can't
member where she read in Pennsylvania I
think is where she from she's from she
went to Nashville so of course people
are alike where she rural America she's
not an urban person mm-hm and so then
when the right-wingers why shouldn't a
right-wingers but like you know the
alt-right people started saying she was
our girl and stuff she reacted by
spinning the direction and becoming
ultra woke overreacted yeah and panic
probably because her business manager
was like who's not a bad does a bad look
for you people not gonna want to give
you money
apparently Taylor I'm sorry you're worth
you're worth two hundred million dollars
if you want to be worth three and sixty
million
you've got to reject this and embrace
woke politics and here we are
how much is too much honestly don't know
I'm completely fine with her making
money
people like her music whatever she's
famous just don't good in front of me
and be a hypocrite don't pretend like
you're poor poor you oh but I would have
done so much better if I was a man okay
Taylor I'll tell you what hold on I'm a
man why don't I have more money than you
I play music I don't play music longer I
was I started playing music when I was
younger than she what haven't recorded
the music yeah I I wish the music I was
12 years old I was 12 years old playing
guitar I couldn't have I couldn't afford
to go to the classes I couldn't afford
to go to Montessori School but I played
music I wrote songs I played at venues
ah what's that I couldn't afford an amp
I couldn't afford a car you want to talk
about what your dad bought you your
that's disgusting you're a rich girl who
got rich because rich people propped you
up and you know what I got no beef you
go do your thing
the problem I have is when you show up
and go I would have done so much better
if I was in
oh shut up you wouldn't I know so many
people who are good at music who didn't
have the privilege she had from her
family and I'm not saying her family I
don't know if her family was like super
rich all I know is like it's it's public
that her dad was like a stock broker
from Merrill Lynch or whatever doesn't
necessarily mean they're worth millions
or anything but Montessori School you
know vocal lessons guitar lessons being
moved to Nashville and having your
connections get you an audition she got
set up totally set up and because of
that because of her access in her ivory
tower she's worth 360 million dollars so
why don't you go cry a little bit more
but you know what here's look here's the
problem she's gonna make money off this
they're gonna eat it up they're gonna
buy it they're gonna spread this trash
she's gonna make more money off it by
manipulating stupid people and that's
the world we live in I kind of worry
more about the ideas that she's sharing
them the fact that she's making money I
don't give a rip how much we're family
friendly expression yeah I don't care
how much money she makes but she's
spreading these ideas that I think are
genuinely bad for society and she's
doing it she's doing it for BS reason so
you just manipulating people for cash
she's like it's it's so obvious that
some like 50-year old guy wrote these
things for her stuck in the 90s for
people right yeah let's good a guy who's
gotta size his morons on it it's like
that was a meme from a long time ago and
like who are you yelling at has she has
this line in her song where she says
something like stop telling you know
stop yelling about all the people you
hate or whatever and I'm like oh are you
talking about like the woke left on
Twitter cuz they hate everybody yeah
isn't that literally what that song is
exactly it's literally it that's what
she's doing but but it's like the same
thing in the other video mm-hmm she's
like how far would I have made it if I
was a man it's like or I don't know when
she's yeah when she's when she's acting
like she says the line people would
question me people wouldn't question me
if I was a man it's like you are right
now literally questioning honey with
that whether or not men deserve what
they have yeah but you know it's it's
not relevant I don't think she cares on
any of this I think she goes home she
does a you know some ridiculous crazy
drug that rich people do like you know
she's doing lines on the she's got she's
got a mirror table with her friends and
you know she's doing whatever I don't
know what she does I'm not saying that
literally I'm saying celebrity Hollywood
types doing their ridiculous celebrity
Hollywood stuff with hundreds millions
of dollars I'm sure she works hard I'm
sure she doesn't care
she's got an infinity pool on the roof
of her you know multi-million dollar
mansion in California and she's laughing
all the way to the bank while we
complain
while we win John the Internet so you
know what I'll tell you what whinging I
learned that word last year it's good
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you